the rays uh well the destinies in their
own hands right now if they win
they are in as the american league east
champions and the american league east
crown would be a nice feather in the cap
they put their third ali's banner up
here at tropicana field their magic
number is down to one two out nobody all
know score leaves it for william thomas
really swings and drives one in the air
towards right field heading back as
mcneal back near the wall and it's gone
home run up onto the second deck for
willie adams
and the rays have taken a one-nothing
lead eighth home run of the season for
willie and i think he hit it off with
facade of that upper deck for the second
deck in
citi field to the opposite field at that
and nice drive there by willie robinson
canoe leading off in the home second
and canoe slams one down the left field
line back toward the corner that ball is
out of here
robinson canoe with the opposite field
home run to tie the game at one
number 10 for canoe and the mets get
even you know robbie had himself a
monumental at bat in his last turn to
the plate last night in the ninth inning
here another long at bat and it results
in an opposite field home run two walks
sandwiched around two strikeouts mcneal
came into the game hitting 325 with four
home runs
breaking ball and it's lifted into
center going to drop in front of
kiermeier he's going to make the throw
to the plate and it will be in time
kiermeier
set that up one hop to center
and he made the play at the plate meyer
had himself all lined up and his throw
in was a one-hopper perez with a super
job to scoop it and tag meyer bails out
snail on the rays into the end of two
it's the mess in the race tied at one
now alonso walked his first time up
and pete slams one out to right center
field back toward the wall that ball is
out of
here peter lonzo goes the other way to
give the mets the lead
number 13 for alonso
oh how he needed that and the mets have
a 2-1 lead in the fourth here's robinson
canoe homer to open the mets scoring in
the second
over the mound adamus right near the bag
throws out canoe for the second out as
dom goes to third lake snow won't be the
winning pitcher 108 pitches he's done
john curtis will come on to face pete
alonso
with the mets leading the race two to
one two out of the six so blake's now
leaves after five and two thirds
gave up six hits couple of runs earned
he's responsible for the man at third
base three walks and nine strikeouts
that's line base it for alonso and in
comes smith with another run this is a
big night for pete alonso a home run and
now a run-scoring single and the mets
laid 3-1
and the reigns are going to see the
left-hander justin wilson
making his 22nd appearance
kevin kiermeier at the plate runners
lead it first and second wendell
bouncing around at second base with the
shortstop rosario trying to keep close
wendell breaks for third of the pitch
boxed by torinos and on a double steal
the raised base runners advance 90 feet
apiece and now a base hit could tie this
game
grounded to third frazier can come home
with it and wendell runs into the tag
and that's the second out now frazier
was the only guy playing in and on that
one hopper wendell was a dead duck at
the plate 5-2 fielder's choice for the
second out and now hunter renfro will
hit against wilson here down in the
count
into the dirt a wild pitch and down the
line from third
comes a run adamus scores and kiermeier
moves up to second into scoring position
and it's a three to two ball game so now
the tying run at second with two out
again the 2-2
struck him out
wilson goes with the cutter to strike
out renfro and keep the mets in front
radia lifts one out to left center
rosarina going back looking up and it's
out of here
guillermo radio with his first hit as a
new york man and it's a home run the
mets third home run of the night and
it's the former ray guillermo herrera
he knew it
lifting the apple and giving the mets a
4-2 lead herrera hit five home runs for
tampa bay in 89 games last year and his
first hit as a met leads the ballpark
well hit by pitch and now two soft hits
alonzo comes up with the bases loaded
and nobody out and alonzo pulls one down
to third wendell's gonna look around and
they get the force at third as a run
comes home and it's five to two new york
and he handled it cleanly he probably
would have come home but he bobbled it
slightly and dom smith scores the run on
the fielder's choice so now a two out
base runner and willy adams will be the
batter
rounded to short rosario circles in
makes the right throw in time of the
ball game is over
diaz gets the save
pete alonso with a breakout night homers
and drives in three and the mets even up
the series with a raise as they win
tonight 5-2